ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon patreon episode returning
favorite giannis pappas is with us in
austin texas
yeah it's good to be here it's good to
be in the new
capital of the world
yeah there's no clubs open yet yes no
clubs but joe's gonna
have one and then cap city will open i
don't know when but
hopefully soon you know i was just sick
i was looking at ben i was going like
you know what they don't teach you that
at college
they don't go you know we're gonna train
you to sit and smoke a cigarette and
yeah produce a podcast
on a beautiful deck overlooking a
beautiful
texas longhorn hill
yeah and they won't sell me this house
because the people
that own it think there it's worth 20
million dollars because they've lost
their minds
but you know what hey elon musk keeps
saying austin
with uh plus signs on twitter so
everybody is just like hey [ __ ] it
if you don't want to pay a a million and
a half dollars for a house that uh would
appraise for
8.50 they go if you're not into that
game
if you want to throw one five cash then
get out of town because
somebody else will i mean somebody who
has a company
somebody who has a tech company uh will
come in here and buy this house cash
and stash their wife and kids there will
they sit in a room and try to figure out
how to
come up with a device that takes
everybody's fingerprints off or whatever
the hell
you went to the texas rancher game i
went to the texas rangers game
today yeah it's the only full capacity
sporting event that has happened in the
united states in over 12 months
yeah texas did it as a middle finger you
know what was funny
is that so it was full capacity nobody
had masks on
half the people are going to die of
covet but you know they're going to
they're going to die
to the star-spangled banner and that's
all they care about in this town and
they're big [ __ ] people
but we were in full capacity nobody was
wearing masks and then on the escalator
they told us
that you couldn't walk on the escalator
because of social distancing
so texas talks about how everyone else
is [ __ ] up
the whole thing is [ __ ] up yeah all
these social distancing
rules don't make sense i'm sitting at a
table put my mask on i get up take it
off put it on take it off
yeah it doesn't matter i got vaccinated
i've had covert why am i wearing a
[ __ ] mask right now
it feels like i'm wearing a condom
having sex with my wife yeah can i just
[ __ ] raw
daddy life right now it doesn't make any
sense uh
you know the media wants covert to keep
going like the media keeps writing
articles where they're like the fifth
wave
don't worry the ninth wave is coming and
we found a mutant strain of covid and
it will it they because trump is gone so
there's nothing left
cloven's the last thing they got have
you seen like the ratings how much
they've dropped in like cnn
yeah they've tanked and they've gone in
the toilet and the media
is gonna they don't know what to do
because they can't really criticize
the president who has clearly has
dementia he has dementia
and it would be a news story um
you know they were always saying like
trump trump seems to be slipping
mentally and maybe he has dementia and
this guy clearly clearly
it has something wrong but he can't talk
about that
so they've got to just talk about uh
they've gotta talk about covid and then
uh
when that is done and that i don't know
when that happens six months a year
whenever
but when that's completely done uh they
might have to turn around and go
why is the president drooling
like why is the president of the united
states
like just completely
but i think that's the point right the
point is that he's just gonna
kamala is gonna take over at a certain
point yeah kamala's just she's waiting
to inherit the throne you know she's
like uh
she's like um anna nicole smith who
married that billionaire
just sitting there going i love you
happy valentine's day sweetheart
can i get you another coffee and then
there's just yeah there's just a little
bit let's just
let's just say it's not micro doughnuts
she's dead right
she's dead she dies she overdosed yeah
yeah
sad i remember her in the naked gun
yeah 33 and the third when i was young
those leslie nielsen movies
back when you could make goofy movies
that weren't about imperialism
yeah uh and uh i remember her and then i
remember she married that old guy and i
remember she had this that show the anna
nicole show yeah
i think it was on e she was a basket
case mess yeah
how many of those shows cause you know
you know like martin you know mark
burnett you had a meeting with him and
everything yeah
it's just so funny that like so many of
you remember whitney houston and bobby
brown had a show
they're just showing up to put cameras
in the face as a drug addict yeah which
is
which which is when tv was good it was
true
it was true i mean doctor joy that shows
celebrity rehab with jeff conaway
i mean they were giving these people no
real help and they just put cameras in
the face the drug it like they did with
anna call they did it with whitney
and some days they would show up and
like these they were too [ __ ] up to
record
and they'd have to like give him water i
mean imagine that imagine like going
through schooling
film school or whatever you went through
and then like you gotta like
you know give a drug addict water so
they can
get up and and finally film a scene
where they scream at their daughter
like you're horrible we'll get this fake
storyline going once
once once we get added nicole smith off
of the iv
yeah we've got to get her up and you
know get
just you know get in with some smelling
salts wake her up but we got
and it's just like that real housewives
show that andy cohen has where
multiple people on the show have off
themselves because the whole show's
about like
being rich and a lot of them have no
money and pretend to be rich
and what happens eventually is one guy
uh
they were pretending to be rich so much
he just off themselves
because it goes they were like they were
like he's like we can't keep doing this
and we can't keep pretending to have
money i know you want to be on the show
but like
you know again he just just took himself
out
yeah on the show yeah yeah i learned
from you
i i'm gonna just i got one person i'm
gonna be honest with you my wife
and then i'm gonna lie i'm gonna start i
gotta start lying more
you guys i told you that i told you just
lie to the people you care about yeah
if you don't lie to the people you care
about i mean you don't really care about
them yeah
i mean you always said that to me who
came up to me in the green room ben
knows exactly this is kind of funny
yeah uh somebody came up to me in the
green room the comedy store goes hey man
he goes i heard you
you did this whole bit on your show
about how you only lie to the people you
care about if you don't
lie to them you don't care about them he
goes dude that was brilliant and i said
oh thanks so much he goes i realized you
were a real deal when i heard that
and that man's name was crystalia i mean
that's true
that's absolutely good yeah but you know
he enjoys the show
that's what matters i don't know what
happened i'm not an attorney
he enjoys the show yeah um no
yeah i mean that i think that's the key
to success is to just
lie you have to you gotta i think i
don't know if it's
straight out lying but it's it's you
can't be too honest with
people right you just can't you have to
lie to them there's
well what you're basically saying is you
have to lie to them because i don't like
anyone
so here's the reality if i were to be
honest with everybody
when as soon as they came up to talk to
me i'd go i'm sorry i don't like you
yeah i would uh hey man i i apologize i
don't
i maybe it's like a misunderstanding i'm
not like i'm not a fan of this
i don't need this in my life but you
can't do that you got to go no no that
sounds good so you're thinking about
starting a podcast yeah oh good yeah
good
yeah no it's good yeah 20 what 20 21
you're gonna start yeah yeah it makes
sense no it's good
i was at the i was at the game today
with a a girl
uh who's from california who moved here
which is like you know that's everybody
right
and uh yeah she told me her father was
two different coaches she gave me two
different names
for and i just pretended to ignore it
you know like so she told me that her
dad was a
was a coach on a on a major league team
she told me his name
and then 10 minutes later she told me
it's a completely different name
so it's two different guys and so she
was lying about it and i wasn't gonna
sit there and go
you know and that's when i started to
think like i need to start just doing
this and just tell people richard gere
is my brother
yeah she was practicing on you because
if this is what i've always said you
gotta lie all the time because you never
know when you're gonna need to be good
at it
it's like drunk driving you can't do it
once in a while you gotta do it every
night or not at all
it's like people learning english as a
second language and they talk to you but
they're really just practicing english
yeah that's what she's doing she's just
trying out a few whoppers on you
yeah to see the next time she's at a job
interview or she's got to lie to a dude
so she could you know
get some of the money or whatever or you
know she's got to lie towards sister or
you know
it it's the way the whole country is run
on
now we have this weird job because we
can be honest
like on these shows and it's funny yeah
but if everyone's lying who's at the
wheel
the best liars yeah the greatest liars
the best players are just
the bushes the clintons the people that
fund them
uh the rockefellers the morgan i mean
historically bezos all these guys like
they lie and create like karl rove said
we're an empire we create our own
reality like
these people just create their own
reality they don't even consider it
lying
they're just inventing truth they're
inventing what they want to be true it's
not absolutely not true and the only
difference between
them and regular liars is regular lives
when they get dehydrated drink a
gatorade and they drink
uh children's blood with adrenaline in
it yes
yeah that's what i was just told well is
that true that they're drinking
adrenaline children a lot i don't think
all of them are triggered adrenal who
told you that at the texas rangers game
the guy was just driving on with an
announcement
yeah they say hell welcome to texas
there's a bunch of pedophiles around in
this area
let me tell you something right now that
pizza place was spooky man
if you went in there was a bob i never
understood the need to believe they're
drinking the judiciary
isn't [ __ ] the kids bad enough i
always said that
because they are [ __ ] the kids but
they go and then they're eating them i
go well wait a minute
yeah and like literally this is what
this is what somebody said to me once
they're trying to explain the key on
horseshit they go
they [ __ ] the kids but they go but then
you gotta hear about the really bad
stuff and i went the really bad stuff
what do you mean i don't understand do
you think there's a chance that alex
jones could have broken to their meeting
and they were drinking wine and he it
just was red and he thought it was
it's possible i do think they kill some
of the kids because if the kids start
getting mouthy
yeah and talking then the kids gotta go
right that's why they want kids from
foster homes
i mean these are evil people that are
doing this they're very evil right
um but now listen are there a cult weird
[ __ ] and has weird [ __ ] happened
absolutely do i think it's do i think
everybody in the world that has money is
doing it
no um do i think pedophiles
exist and are protected i know for a
fact yeah like
high-level members of the government or
just regular rich people
are you know if you're a poor pedophile
you just grab a kid off the street if
you're a rich pedophile
there's a business around it well it's
like there's a church around
a whole institute you can make it based
on facts you could probably make an
argument that maybe the catholic church
was
set up as a ruse to systematically rape
children
it's not the worst argument i mean the
day the evidence
kind of points that way that is not the
worst argument i mean it points that way
like it's weird when somebody when i
mean think about it they're against
abortion of course they're against
abortion
what's their supply their supplies
unwanted kids yes
so you never [ __ ] with a motherfucker's
supply that's a good point kill that kid
send him to our seminary i always get
weird when like somebody tells me their
son's thinking about being a priest i go
oh he's a better like
immediately i jump to that right if
somebody goes this young kid's thinking
about being a priest i go
what and think about it who who is an
authority figure you call him father
who do you never question he's a
representative of god don't question him
father he's name his father
right give my son to him unwanted son to
him he's going on a ball game trip you
know what i mean
in father's basement you know so it's
like that's where the ball game's
happening
and you don't question that parents
never say anything i'd love to get in
there to the vatican bank and see what
they got cause they got a lot oh they
got a [ __ ] you know how you
when you're going to 7-eleven they've
got a slurpee machine yeah they got an
adrenaline machine
it's just yeah i just learned i just
learned the word today on the ride back
who said who told you that texas
everyone in texas is saying this
idiot that you drove with i mean it's
just yeah i mean it's just there's
there's things going on i mean there's
[ __ ] children's blood
that have painted the walls of the world
it's not taxes it's literally everywhere
and uh and it's probably true at this
point
you know what i mean it's it's true
enough i thought gasoline maxwell was a
good
good gal what'd you what'd you call it
just lean mass well
goddess is in mid-stroke he calls david
dobrik daniel dobrik all the time
i don't know and you gotta go full
boomer you're about to go full-blown no
none of these people have any importance
to me so i never learned their names i
know but you should
know one name it's joe rogan yeah come
kick me in the chest i'll move here or
tell you i am at least
it's uh i can't go back to new york you
know i look at new york and i go i love
new york but it's like a part of the
past
and la is just is on fire literally and
figuratively
and uh they just turned david dobrik
into a rapist
so you look at la you gotta kick la so
austin's kind of
it at the moment like i don't want to go
back to i don't want to go back to
getting on a subway
and getting off a subway and like
running around doing spots i'll do it
every now and then like i'll jump over
there and
and do comedy but like as a lifestyle i
don't want that
lifestyle yeah no because i did it for
years so did you
yeah i don't think you have to anymore
yeah some of that is uh it's a good
problem to have kind of
i think what you're calling i think what
you're saying is
without saying it yeah is your
socio-economic status
doesn't really jive with the subway
anymore but nobody's does
yeah here's the thing actually nobody's
does
if you think about the amount of time
you spend
doing bar shows and if you just took
if you found a few people that were
funny well tim warner's not going to be
able to hop
in his i mean he's living tesla yeah
nobody even knows who he is but he's
living in like a van he's a sweet kid
but it's not working burns newspapers
for he
yeah but the idea that people just have
ignored the internet forever and have
said
we're just gonna rely on like the people
that own comedy club and let's be very
honest
the people that own comedy clubs or book
comic
these are the same types of people that
were
outside of a tent selling tickets to a
bearded lady
or a [ __ ] two sisters that conjoined
twins
the same person that was selling like
tickets to come see the conjoined twins
is now the booker of stand-up new york
or whatever club you fill in like and
that's what i liked about the pandemic
is they they finally took their circus
outside
yes and they said you know what can are
you available for
for the 8 15 one train show
it was they started doing shows and
tents yeah yeah and it felt like a
circus it felt like a literal circus
they did a clean show in one car and
then you moved around to the late show
hosted by jay ockerson in the in the
second car yeah
i mean my ex-roommate guys like that man
they're part of the history of american
entertainment because they would have
been in like the depression era tent
carnival circuit
yeah like the dust bowl you know they
would they just
came up like they're that that type of
person
uh has had a place in entertainment
forever it's never
the successful place but it's always a
place there's always a guy
who's like come this way see the sights
like and then there's also uh like uh an
overseer carnival guy who's like
whipping the bearded lady and that's
what the bookers and club owners due to
the comics
you're good to be here welcome sit at
your water station and gossip
basically the cellar table it's a
[ __ ] water station where waitresses
gossip
yes it's i've never spent that much time
there i mean obviously it's like
legendary did you did you enjoy your
half
off chicken fingers yeah
and your 75 dollar check that will be
taxed
it's it's it's a crazy business like the
idea of
being employed
in this business is weird especially in
2020 it's weird being employed you got
to take a little ownership of your
certainty people got to do it and i get
it
but it's very strange to have like a
boss and have people tell you what to do
and have people
rat on you and like if you don't have a
good set
uh a waitress will tell somebody and
then they go hey what happened down
there it's like
it's a very strange thing to have to
conform to what's kind of an archaic
that's a lot of clubs it's everywhere
it's just like
it's just the way that it works and that
people
just do it and it's kind of
unquestioningly do it yeah and i
never understood the comedy club system
where on a tuesday it was
25 or like how about this one on
thursday it's 25
shows sold out friday all of a sudden
i'm getting 75 dollars
right how did what's that miss lighting
what's that difference yeah
yeah can you show me that magic trick
slow motion argument is that people
drink more on friday but that's not true
no because it's a two drink minimum yeah
and a lot of those people on tuesday
they're on a vacation getting bombed
yeah yeah so i'd like to i'd like to see
that magic trick in slow motion it'll be
fun to go back and do a few spots but
and and you know i'm excited for joe's
club to open because i want to be
somewhere new
i don't want to come out of this
pandemic the way i went into it
and i think being in a new club a new
state a new environment
is much better than going back to the
same things that i used to do
even the store which i love but like the
same types of things to me
i mean my spots at the store used to be
like 1am
not when i am i'd get like 11 30 spots
right which were decent spots for a guy
that just got past
but the three people before me would
bomb a lot of the times
and they had nothing going on no family
they simply got those spots because they
were passed at the club
longer than i was they didn't have a
podcast they have anything going on they
weren't on tv or any of that
they just they would get the spot
because it was like hey they put in the
time
and it's like what the [ __ ] does that
mean remember that i remember
yeah i would go there and you know you'd
go up late and people would cheer they
were there to see you yeah
it was just weird because it was like
you waited around and then people would
go up and they'd be like
yeah you know this guy's been here for
15 years and i'm like who cares
yeah what does that mean what i love
about like uh you know jeremy
piven and michael rappaport is that
they're waiting they're waiting to get
good they're waiting to get good before
they do weekends
yeah they're waiting to put 10 20 years
in because they know that the audience
really cares about the craft yeah you're
going you know what
michael rapport was good but he wasn't
technically as good as some of the guys
i saw
at this comedy club on a tuesday night
what i love about jeremy piven is he's
the only guy that got me
to into comedy like he got me two
into stand-up because you can see how
stand-up's like the lowest art form ever
yeah
people that have had serious me too
problems take refuge in stand-up comedy
yeah
cause they're like i mean i walked into
state of new york like jeremy piven was
on stage
and you're just looking at him like what
the hell happened to that guy
yeah i knew you just know that he wanted
to do the podcast yeah and we just
didn't answer
screech and stevo you know you go from
like
you can't staple your balls at 50. so
it's like but you can
go up on a stage and tell jokes it's
like stand-up is like the statue of
liberty it'll take whatever
what give me your weary you're tired
you're damaged you're molested your
former
carnival stars give me your former child
nerd [ __ ] screech rest in peace yeah
i mean nobody ever
learned his name but he you know he was
able to diamond dusted diamond he was
available to do
a weekend in side splitters yeah he was
around
he was available he definitely hit uh
did a couple cycles of soul joel
yeah well it's what i love about i was
we would do the sojourn gig and i love
social but you know they click
the green room was a little you said the
green room was a little because it had
floor mats
well first of all
i like what they do with the place but
the floor mats need to be winterized
yeah
the green room was a car it was the
escalade which was nice but also they
didn't pay
for the kerosene or for the heat lamps
or whatever they were putting in the
heat lamps
so the second shell we're all like kind
of up there half bombing because it was
freezing
people are in in blankets with ski masks
on and i'm entertaining them in the
middle of a field in pennsylvania and i
was like
oh this is the end of the world you did
feel like that you go
this is the [ __ ] end of the world
yeah
it's kind of uh it was kind of a propo
though that like the capital comedy
became royersford pa during a pandemic
that's very fast that our country could
not handle because we are a failed
state in every way in every way when it
comes to car and home insurance don't we
deserve
better i know i do i put my policy
to test and turn to gabby they literally
stand for
get a better insurance gabby
get a better insurance
they are the one true comparison
platform with real rates they give you
an apples-to-apples comparison
of your i am in a safe house by the way
i know that many of you are
looking at this going where is where is
he recording these ads from it is a safe
house
uh they give you apples to apples
comparison of your current coverage with
40 of the top insurance providers
progressive nationwide travelers all in
one place
use current insurance information to get
started and just minutes you'll be able
to see quotes for the exact same
coverage
you have now it's free to use all you
got to do
is uh go to gabby.com sign up with a
promo code
or you just do gabby.com tim dillon
gabby g-a-b-i
dot com slash tim dillon listen average
people the average customer receives 961
dollars per year on
average how does that sound jared
good does it sound good 961 dollars per
year on
average they'll never sell your info so
no annoying spam or
robo calls put your policy to the tesla
guide get a better insurance
with gabby it's totally free no
obligation
gabby.com tim dillon that's g-a-b-i
dot-com slash tim dillon
better help better help
online counseling for you when you need
it
better help will assess your needs in
matching with your own licensed
professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it's not a crisis line or
self-help
it is professional counseling done
securely online there's a broad range of
expertise available which may not be
locally available in many areas
the service is available for clients
worldwide you can log in your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor
you can get timely and thoughtful
responses plus if you don't like your
counsel you can just get another one
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available
betterhelp wants you to stop starting
people want you to start
living a better life today visit their
website read their testimonials that are
posted daily
that's better hlp.com and join the over
1 million people who have taken charge
of their mental health with the help of
an experienced professional
so many people are using better help
that they had to recruit
additional counselors in all 50 states
i'm in a hotel room right now
and by calling better help and speaking
to a counselor i will one day have the
strength to leave
and face the world how exciting is that
better help it's better hlp you can
speak to people
they love it this podcast is sponsored
by better help
and tim dillon show listeners get 10 off
their first map their first month not
month
their first month at betterhelp.com
tim d that's betterhelp.com
what do you think of austin i mean
you're staying downtown it's a dump
i think um it might everyone who's like
has any semblance of reason has
retreated here
yeah and that's what scares me because
you know like venezuelans cubans when
they escaped
uh you know they escaped to america they
swam here on rafts or on their tt's back
or whatever
and you know and there was some ant who
was drowning but then the the
the niece and she just said go you know
go live freedom and they made it
and now i get the sense that people who
have like any sense of reason or in the
middle
politically or have common sense are
moving they're moving to austin
they're moving to texas they're moving
to dallas they're moving to fort worth
they're moving to florida and the thing
is that's still in america
so there's just nowhere to hide yeah
there's nowhere to run there's nowhere
to hide
there's there's a real worry that
and we talked about this people
are a lot of people are just
disconnected the elites are completely
disconnected from any of the problems
that are happening
uh they believe all of the problems are
on social media on twitter which they've
all created by the way but
none of them understand that like
cleveland is a bombed out third world
hellhole
that kansas city and omaha nebraska when
you drive through them
uh look like you're in bosnia you look
like you're in a
kurt russell it looks like this escape
from new york yeah yeah
there's tenth city in every major city
there's large communities of tent cities
yeah
there's boarded up houses just boarded
up and if you bring this up people look
at you like you've done the wrong thing
right by bringing it up they go wait a
minute what
they don't want any reality to puncture
their idea
of you know what's going on but it's bad
out there i mean even dallas
dallas i don't want to walk around here
no you know you go see the x in the spot
and then you
cities work like sharks when if they
stop moving they die if a city stops
moving
which is what happened with covert these
things die when you close the
restaurants to shops and all this
stuff there's just nowhere to go there's
nothing to do
and then the cities become vacant people
leave
homeless people move in they set up
camps those people
have mental health problems that the
government doesn't doesn't give them any
help with
those people that set up these you know
barter economies of drugs and sex or
whatever else
and this is what happens i mean it's
like the cities get deserted manhattan
got deserted everybody was working from
home
yeah so like people move in and they go
hey okay this is fun
tesla tesla's gonna take the homeless
people in austin
and just send them out in into space
that's the secret that people don't know
that rudy giuliani used to put him on
buses and send him to the west coast he
would send him upstate new york we're
upstate all over the place
i mean elon musk and uh all his tech
cronies here are just going to put him
on
what's your read on a guy like him on
elon musk yeah because he's a new
hairline i know that
very he's brilliant but he's also kind
of a hockster
he's all over the place he loves fame
yes and he's a visionary but it's also
like
hard as it is he's married like a
celebrity like mc squared is her name
right yeah
grimes and his daughter is like a
[ __ ]
name the computer code right he likes
attention he's like
he hangs out with kanye west you know he
can't understand a word kanye west is
saying right but he did it for the gram
like it's
it's wild to have a billionaire be one
of the richest people
on the planet and you know he's also
doing things for the gram
yeah which is just let you know that you
know nobody has any tact anymore
no there's no i will say one thing about
the morgans and rockefellers like
there was a little there was there was
something nice about the idea of uh
just a an evil billionaire locked away
in a castle
now they're like on twitter all the time
bothering you right it's like have the
decency to not
that's what i like about warren buffett
he's he just stays in his little hut in
omaha because he's a little goblin
and he's got that fraudulent garbage you
know i'm i like my house which you don't
uh god only knows why he stayed there
but he's a goblin
and he stays there in his little hut and
just
is worth a hundred billion dollars and
emerges every now and then like a
groundhog
uh to tell everybody things are going to
be okay and then buys five companies
yeah you know that's something nice
about it he's not on twitter all the
time i don't think he is
is he ben you know no he's not he's not
there's something nice about that yeah i
don't know
like elon musk there's something a
little weird about someone who's uh
such a big billionaire who wants the
love of the people why do you want the
admiration i guess
all the things he wants to do he's got
these grand designs and the way society
should be run he needs some type of
public support
i think we don't deserve it though yeah
take take your [ __ ]
rocket ship and go to mars well me and
ben talk about it all the time
the next step and is is you know we were
talking to a guy the other day goes i
want to build my own city
um that's going to be next where
billionaires will just build their own
cities that are smart cities where
uh in order to get in they're going to
look at your credit score medical
history this type the other thing
it's going to be retinal eye scan you
know it'll be biometric all that
[ __ ]
and uh you know it would be a better
place man i mean look at what we've done
with freedom i mean we had it we had a
little experiment here where they said
what do the people want and the people
want
the people said i want nachos with
liquid cheese
that's what they said it really is true
democracy really is not
saying i want a buffet with limitless
options
yeah i want to be able i don't want to
be able to walk i want to be
i want you to invent the device that
will roll me there
yeah it's true it's a tough it's a tough
argument right now to make for democracy
yeah
i mean this is a tough podium to stand
on to talk about how great tomorrow i
mean there are companies that move
cars yeah and now that those companies
are moving people
yeah that are on wheels yeah they're
saying i'll move you're moving you're
relocating i will move
i would send your car to you and i'll
also send you your grandmother
and by the way your grandmother was just
as heavy as the car there's also
something about the idea of like
the the diet of content that we fed
ourselves from like
trash talk shows to reality show i mean
just
mind-numbingly bad entertainment
uh for decades and
bad food bad entertainment bad news well
that's the thing and we've rotted our
brains everyone's brains rot that's why
queueing on it like
it takes hold pretty easily because
people's brains have been rotted they've
been rotted
and they have no love for knowledge i
mean it's like
you just say to a kid what would you
rather read the autobiography of
abraham lincoln or the notebook and
they'll take the notebook every [ __ ]
time right
so it's like that's we've kind of
non-fiction is just not as [ __ ] lit
as fiction and right now it needs to be
[ __ ] lit okay if you are not an
influencer slash merch dropper slash
tick tocker slash boxer slash chinese
spy
you are not employed it is [ __ ] if
you don't have a job unless you're jake
paul yeah if you're not a chinese
scientist or south asian doctor yeah
you better be jake paul right
that's it there's not a lot out there
there's not a lot out there dude
there's not a lot of jobs out there
they've been eliminated there's no
travel agents i remember
like everything is computers have taken
everything right i mean there's
something to what
you can do but are you now if you need a
travel agent if you need a travel agent
yeah you're you're you're a mongoloi
you're a muggler
and but what jobs did those people get
that used to work in liberty travel
where did they go
do they are they all handing out buzzers
at panera bread where are they
yeah they're in a tent yeah they've got
to be in a tent yeah that's true
what are they doing yeah that's why like
people are surprised at the cancelling
that canceling that's a whole economy
yeah that's a job
that's a new job that's emerged that is
necessary
that's true yeah those people need to be
employed they need to take people down
so they can eat
yeah they're not they're not outraged by
what you said they're just trying to eat
yeah because it's a story and people
will read it
well we we say you know we go on the
road and like you know airbnb now is
like
like you walk into a hotel now there's
like no one there right like hotels now
we're like done
yeah you can just go stay at some guy's
house massive you walk into a hyatt yeah
there's just empty conference rooms yeah
no no businesses are doing conferences
because they're covered and by the way
they're not going to start doing them
either because they go we're saving all
this [ __ ] money
so you walk through a hyatt and and
you're like there's no one there there's
like one guy at the front desk because
hi it's like
we're not employing anybody anymore
there's like three people
you're in a carcass of what used to be a
functional hotel
like a massive hotel me and ben have
been the only people me ben or dan like
we're walking around these hotels
there's like they're spooky yeah there's
nobody in them
and they're desolate wastelands no dude
we're all everyone
only fans is like yeah we're just
monetizing
feet ourselves feet yeah if you you know
if you have a fetish you just go on only
fans
it's like you have to monetize
everything you have to be fully
monetized
pretty soon instead of renting out your
house aaron b you'll start renting out
family members and giving them to people
you'll move and be like do you want to
you want to traffic my daughter
you could stay at my house it's run by a
management company
and there's also my daughter there's a
management company that handles my
daughter to be traffic for a week yeah
we're monetizing our own homes yeah our
lives
our family members everything is content
you gotta have a monetization yeah i
mean if you've got nice feet showing
and we're headed towards a big crash
like so like this nft style headed
towards it
like you mean we're to acknowledge it
soon yeah
like what's interesting about the nft
stuff is like you know
which we are at a t what do we close at
10 10k
i thought it was gonna go for 80 million
dollars
man now what is nft's because i'm a
boomer
it's a non-fungible token ben ben
explains this better than i can
it's essentially a type of digital art
could be video
that's how you know we're done we're
[ __ ] dealing each other imaginary
stuff there's imaginary money
there's imaginary art for a second
screen grab from your podcast i'm
explaining giannis what's happening with
digital real estate now people are going
to own houses online now
let give ben a few minutes here okay
giannis so
do you know about the game decentraland
it's it's an ai game
that people can go in and be it
literally listen to this because this is
scary
i'll explain it to you like you can go
in it it's like sims you remember sims
yes with those games where you could be
whoever you want have a house and a wife
now people are going in and buying plots
of land within the game
for like 80k to build a home because
it's in a prime
part of the town to build something on
so people are legitimately going in
a hundred thousand are the art you're
gonna hang in the fake home
right fungible means it can be
replicated or duplicated non-fungible
what's going on guys like i didn't know
about this so what what's going on
that's not we're moving into the
computers
that's not real we're moving into the
game because detroit and cleveland and
and omaha and all these places are
garbage
but you can't live in a computer yeah
but you could live in a pod
you could have like a little pod and
then you just get there and everything
of value that you have will be in a
computer yeah
everything cool when you take out your
phone you go look at this cool thing i
own
yeah it's going to be on your phone and
then your house is going to be on a
computer because your real house
is going to be uh a tiny little
apartment
pod or it'll be because that's what
they're gonna do it'll be mega cities
with pods it'll be green energy
it'll be like you can't own a car
anymore you're not allowed to do that
can't do this can't do that
whatever it is the environment whatever
it is you'll you'll be relegated to a
small
district nine type of thing and
everything of value that you own
and all of your formative experiences
are all going to be
predominantly digital the term is
digitally native kids are digitally
native because they grow up on the
internet right their first boyfriend or
girlfriend or friend
is on the internet right everything's
the internet i mean so
pretty soon they'll probably have sex
where they have sensors on right and you
can like be in virtual reality
there's gonna be sex dolls oh yeah
nobody has sex anymore i mean sex is
like forget it like
the levels of people having sex has
dropped dramatically everybody's on porn
there's 24 year olds with e.d
yeah because of porn they jerk off all
day it's
someone's like oh that's a porn star you
go no that's my teacher she's just
it's the summer and she's on fans only
yeah yep
only fans yeah whatever it is
i try not to remember it i don't know
what i'm gonna how i'm gonna raise my
daughter in this world i have a daughter
now yeah
and like i know when she turns five
she's gonna sit me down and talk about
toxic masculinity and [ __ ] how i'm a
patriarch and
you know how how i need to accept a few
people of color into our family
she's gonna force me to adopt people
like i'm scared about what it's going to
be like to raise
her i'm going to have to wait for her to
choose her gender it's like if we're
letting kids choose their gender at five
why not force them to tell us their
politics too
right they need to if you're gonna
choose gender you should let me know
whether you're republican or democrat do
that buy five you should do that bet
yeah i just get it on your podcast
that's the future
i'm not gonna do it on stage why would i
do it look i'm doing it here now for
more people i just did it for 18 to 19
000 people i'm not gonna go do it for 50
people at the [ __ ] stand
okay you know what i'll do if you want
to pay to see me yeah i'll stand up
daddy long day's patreon yeah and i'll
do exactly what michael rappaport does
is just make an appearance yeah i'll
just stand up there and just talk to the
crowd and say so what did you do today
i got your 100 bucks at a ticket because
you're fans cause you heard me on the
tim dillon show yeah i'm not
learning how to tell jokes anymore hey
giannis here you go this is from
bloomberg today
sophia the humanoid robot just sold her
nft digital artwork for 688 000
with plans to create more wow so a robot
just sold
an nfc wow yeah i mean i know people
that can't
find a job in the physical world and a
robot just sold an nft for 700k
yeah yeah i mean good luck everyone yeah
good luck and it's also
this is a perfect time for us to be
investing trillions of dollars into
trying to figure out how to breathe on
mars
yes
here we go we're gonna you know it's
depressive to think of a future of not
living on mars here's the problem with
mars
yeah you can't breathe on it yeah so
we're gonna have to figure out a way to
send people there that's the thing with
elon musk he just keeps blowing up
spaceships
in the sky while no one can get
vaccinated or healthcare
but we're just blowing up spaceships
yeah
we can't even figure out how to beat a
pandemic i think it's going to take a
little bit more
than a decade to figure out how to
colonize a planet you can't breathe on
yeah i mean if you can't breathe on
there you can't grow food there right
you're gonna have to figure out some
sort of they'll have to they're gonna
terraform them they'll terrible
they'll figure it out this we're gonna
watch them all leave not us but someone
will
some generation we'll watch them all go
and we'll just still be here and you
know that's the thing though like
i always remember how stupid i am yeah
and like
we generally are right because like that
you're right they will figure it out
they'll figure out a way to grow some
[ __ ] like
to me it's just like i'd be like how did
how do you grow a cheese sandwich
how do you grow a sandwich that's what i
would say but i don't even know what
terraforming
or any of that is i'm just like grow me
a pizza
because that's all that's what i would
think you'd have to do to survive on
mars
but they'll figure it out we had a good
run this was a good run no maybe but
maybe they'll escape to a pot on mars oh
they will maybe it'll be like you just
are you on most joe rogan
and kamala harris and they'll just
escape
that's a fun pod that'll be a fun part
what if joe had her on i'd love
what if the vice president went on his
show and did that maniacal laugh
i just did that maniacal laugh and he
confronted her and he said you put a lot
of people in prison
and she looked at him and she went joe
shut the [ __ ] up
and he passed her a joint she started
getting high like what
why not you know like she goes joe shut
the [ __ ] up and she just starts getting
high and lifting off
like at a certain point it's like why
not
yeah you know yeah she'd go you know
they'd get high and paranoid and start
like they do if they did shrooms be like
he's showing a picture bigfoot
like you're not really african-american
he's like who cares joe i mean
you're not a journalist either okay
you're a fighter they just start
laughing yeah they're just like it's all
the same dude i mean common
interviewed serena recently you know the
accredited journalist common
wait it went into defeat he did it
serena williams it was just like and i
just so it was common
interviewing her she chose to be
interviewed by comments yeah so like
there is no journalism anymore
it's all facebook posts yeah you read an
article there's no different it's like
reading some
mentally ill person's facebook post
it is true you do read the l.a times and
you go oh this is my aunt
this is just my aunt's facebook page
that someone paid for
yeah and i put in the i haven't touched
a physical newspaper in
years yeah no there because yeah you
look down it looks like you were jerking
off a coal miner for ten seconds and
then every now and then you'll be in
like a hotel in one of these towns
you're performing it and they'll have
like
some the omaha herald or something there
and you're like who the [ __ ]
how is this still going on yeah how do
you even
have the budget to print
a lot of these local small town papers
which used to do
decent journalism not that one but some
of them did
and they're all gone and it's weird
yeah because that's the world we live in
now you can be whatever you want
like serena can just say oh i want to do
a big interview
i'll choose who's going to interview me
it's going to be a rapper who's also an
actor
right you know common so it's like all
the walls have been broken now
we're living in like an impressionist
painting like there's just no structure
there's no lines it's just this is just
a [ __ ] justin pollock
and i did that on purpose next
we disappear into dots yeah into a syrah
i love those writers or not the writers
the [ __ ] like interviewers were like
what's next so what's next for you tyra
banks
yeah i don't know another talk show
the podcast is sponsored by blue chew
guys it's been a hell of a year percy i
feel like i've aged 12 years over the
last 12 months and if you're like me
you're feeling your age more than you
used to
especially in the bedroom it's time to
snap out of it i love bluetooth and copy
they're like
how can we have the host insult himself
in order to sell our product it's simon
snapping it's like you got to be like my
dick doesn't work
and i bet yours doesn't either hey do
you ever look at your dick and you're
like
this thing is not going to work blue
chew
is a unique online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis
but in chewable form and at a fraction
of the cost
luchu is an online prescription service
no visits to the doctor no awkward
conversations no waiting in line at the
pharmacy ad
it ships right to your door in a
discreet package the process is simple
simonblue2jack.com consult with one of
their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days and the
best part it's all done online
don't like swallowing pills no problem
it's chewable bluetooth
blue chew is chewable it's made in the
usa
it's one of the only things left made in
usa and they prepare and ship direct so
it's cheaper
than a pharmacy how fun is that so if
you could benefit from extra confidence
when it's time to perform visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
and we've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free
when you use promo code td at checkout
just pay five dollars shipping
that's b l u e c h ew bluetooth.com
promo code td to receive your first
month free
and we thank bluetooth for sponsoring
the podcast it's great even if your dick
works
blue chew is good because it tastes good
and it's good to chew and eat so even if
your dick works you can just eat blue
chew as a snack
while you're on the go or at your job
and you will have a hard dick and you
will perform
and that's what it's all about it's
about performing
and having a hard dick and isn't that
nice
don't we all want a hard dick all right
blue chew everybody promo code
t d sleep is so important
helix sleep has a quiz that takes two
minutes to complete and it matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress
for you everyone's unique and helix
knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they're soft medium firm
cooling you down if you sleep hot
heating up if you sleep cool
i took the helix quiz it was matched
with a great model that i love
it's firmer i like a firm mattress so if
you're looking for mattress take the
quiz you order the mattress that you're
matched to
you can add on sheets or pillows or
whatever else you need for your bed and
then the mattress comes right to your
door
within 10 business days you don't ever
need to go to a mattress store again
i love it everyone loves it ben loves it
everybody has them they're all great and
everybody enjoys it it's awesome you
don't need to take my word for it they
were awarded number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020
by gq and wired magazine just go to
helixsleep.com tim dillon
take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life they have a 10-year warranty
and you'll get to try it out for 100
nights risk-free they'll even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but you
will
now what's good about um
the helix mattress as opposed to other
mattresses
is that uh this has been a mattress
that's really custom
for you not even so much just a
broad spectrum of people just for you
and because you've taken the quiz
and you're gonna love it i love it
it's the greatest thing i've ever done
in my life is get the helix mattress
every
other professional accomplishment
personal trying pales in comparison
to my i would sleep all day all night if
i could for the rest of my life
i hate waking up waking up is a problem
uh so if you like me just want to sleep
forever
helix is the way to go so and listen
they're offering up to two hundred
dollars off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for listeners
at helixsleep.com tim dillon did you
hear that 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at helix
sleep.com
tim dillon helixsleep.com dylan
i cannot believe that they're being that
generous
um but they are
and you should take the quiz get the
mattress use the code
uh mattresses are important and you need
them
thank you i just i'm excited
for like i i for tv to [ __ ] buy the
tim dillon show and ruin it yeah
i'm excited for like i want to see and i
haven't seen this yet like
i want to see like fallon and kimmel and
people like that start having
on-air breakdowns like on-air
breakdowns where they start losing their
mind i want to see true tv's new lineup
that's what i'm excited for are you do
you well i mean we should say a little
bit about you have a new podcast i have
a new podcast yes and it's called yanni
long days
long days with giannis pappas and it is
on youtube it's on youtube and you can
subscribe where
you can subscribe uh on youtube itunes
spotify
patreon.com yanni long days for bonus
episodes
which i do in my bathtub because that's
my studio
just like common is serena's interviewer
now
fans have asked on my platforms
is there any chance i have to ask of
a uh a history hyenas either uh
some type of any kind of episodes in the
future
i thought you were about to say boxing
match uh well i was gonna say
reconciliation but i don't want to get
into the term reconciliation because
that implies that there's something
wrong
but there's nothing wrong so i was just
saying
is there a chance we're gonna oh we're
opening
yeah we're opening for ben askren and
jake paul oh yeah yeah okay
that's a good gig that's a great if you
guys wrangled that that's a great
[ __ ]
just get open for that and it's not a
physical fight it's more of a screaming
one yeah
but so they're kidding i'm joking yeah
of course yeah and so there's
it's it's it's can people still listen
old episodes
yes history hyenas is up forevers i
recommend you come over to long days
we're continuing the tradition of
of uh you know that type of humor yeah
and um it's uh come over to hyenas or
you can go to hey
uh uh chris has a podcast hey babe or
chaos
so go to those if you want to listen to
us but yeah those episodes of history
are up forever but and unfortunately
that show ended
yes and it was a great show great show
and both of you guys are gonna do good
yeah separately i mean ben ben and me
are breaking up ben's gonna do his own
show
uh very soon and uh you know but we
we will still remain friends ben's gonna
do his own show where he will giggle
into a microphone and i will do my own
show
i don't know how to upload anything so i
will just scream at the sky
scream at this guy would be a great name
for a special yeah and i will scream at
the sky
and just sit there and figure it out i i
don't
ben literally runs my life to the degree
where i don't know how money comes goes
in or out of my bank account i don't
know how anything happens
without ben i would literally have to
take a class like a college course on
how to live
yeah i just don't have a clue no i don't
understand how anything works
ben understands how everything works and
that
is what we need more of to create
jobs and that is laziness yes
so yes because the jobs can actually
be done yes by one person yeah
or a computer right we need to continue
to get lazier and lazier to just hire
someone to do
something else yes i agree right well
you need food tasters
we believe in the division of labor yes
so pretty soon you need to start hiring
a full staff to
like one person person cuts your
toenails yes the other one makes sure
that
your rabbit is rare you like it rare
if it's a if it's a little past rare you
have someone else you've hired
that gets that meat thrown at him and
his job is to receive the meat in the
face
and that's the way we create a new
economy um
in america there needs to be uh
yeah there needs to be some type of we
don't make anything any
here's the thing it's hard for us to
understand how how
bad it is because we we you know it's
hard there's an old greek expression you
know the camel can't see his own hump
if you look at every asian city right
now
they look like what our cities used to
look like
at the dawn of the industrial revolution
like it's all relative people looking up
going wow
now in this tech world you look at those
asian cities in malaysia and china
you're going
wow because they're they're they are
the result of this era whereas our
cities are
the demise from another one they're the
the it's like
they're like ours are museums right our
cities are museums they're not
functioning
[ __ ] you know it's like there's two
what is it one
tech hub it's like sunnyvale san fran
and now austin's gonna be
and the rest of them are just pittsburgh
it's just hipsters running around
selling coffee to each other
yeah there's no industry here it's
people moving into old factories and
making them into like barbecue
restaurants pretty soon there's gonna be
white women from here who are opening up
nail salons in china
yeah that's gonna happen soon yeah
that's wild i'm ready to move there and
surrender tomorrow
yeah well we do need china to come in
here
and and and kick start the economy a
little bit yes we do need it
because i don't think i don't think
people getting drown is all bad
truly yeah truly i think certain people
well we can't go down this road because
every time we've done a podcast in the
past because this happened people
haven't unearthed an old pocket as we
did
when you're when your show was tim
dillon goes to hell yeah where we talked
about how we need a plague to come
wow that's a great yeah and it happened
and then it happened
that's very interesting because we did
talk about that we did
talk about so when we're joking is
saying hey china should come here
that might happen i told you how they're
going to come here dude they're going to
come they're coming
and they're hitting malibu first they're
setting up their captain's quarters and
wrists
reese witherspoon's beach house and then
there's stormin
pepperdine and the hype house yeah
they're gonna take out taylor holden
first
and they're gonna taylor holder but how
do you know who taylor holder is
because i watch wow talk to find out
what the kids are doing
very good that was amazing yeah i like
the low price brothers i think the lopez
brothers too are
in hot water they're good dancers what
they do not in hot water on
uh anthony kamiah's network they're in
hot water for talking to teenagers
underage teenagers how old are they the
lopez brothers to me look they like they
can be anywhere between 15 and 35.
i don't know how old they are they're
23. yeah and they were talking to like
13 year olds right
yeah and his younger brother's 19. they
danced it off though they danced it off
no comment dance off that criticism they
danced off the rush that dirt off your
shoulder
yeah because the allegations came and
literally the older lopez brother
uh just doesn't he hate hannah stocking
she left him because he was trying to
talk to a 13 year old you know more
about this than us
i do i do you know everything giannis
just comes in here
says he doesn't know anything and he
honestly is more about the drama
of the tick tock yeah both hannah and
laylee are besties
yes yeah that's true they're besties and
they both were nerds when they were
younger and they loved people
you know their old manager or their
current manager yeah i mean
hannah stocking is getting close to 30.
yeah
and i think when she turns 30
she's gotta what do you do you can't be
can you be
can you be lit on tick tock in your 30s
well
those are she's a youtuber uh and you
can be in your 30s on youtube yeah you
could be in your 30s on youtube
you know uh jason nash is sweet guy he's
in his ministry
tick tock is purely pedophilia
well it it if you're on tick tock
and you're like an older person you're
either bait or a pedophile you're doing
something
something's up i tried to be funny on
tick tock for a little bit and then i
just gave up
because i was like i don't have it in me
even though i was doing decent like
we're like
we tried for what two weeks two weeks
yeah two three weeks i mean and then i
just said i don't have an ending
i don't even in me to like do another
one
do you like i just don't have it in me
like i built the instagram uh we built
the twitter up i go
i don't have it in me to do another
one right i don't have an image right i
feel that way about
my podcast right now yeah
like oh i got to do this all over again
yeah tick-tock was fun for two weeks
and that was it do you think what's
coming next
uh with this podcast boom is that there
will be like
a a lou perlman of podcasts who starts
putting together like a
new kids on the black pack like podcast
where he's getting
he gets like one handsome one one
dangerous one
one from this side of the tracks one
closeted gay one
yeah i could be i think the podcast
boom's about done
i think it's about over and i think the
good ones will survive
the ones that are funny the ones that
are interesting
but i think the idea that everybody
having one or celebrities
just having them because they're bored
yeah uh
is that's over right that's gonna go
away
and i think the people that have been in
it for a while that are good at it
will stay and they will
evolve and they will keep putting out
good [ __ ]
but i think the idea of a podcast as a
vehicle for people
is starting to turn i mean ben you you
you kind of pay a lot of attention to
stuff what do you think
yeah yeah it's it's it's definitely on
its way out there's
there's way too many people with way too
many shows but i will say a lot of those
shows are just being ignored as well
right so tim's kind of right and and i
know you're joking about the
getting the ragtag young group of people
into the yeah but no one
it doesn't work right it just doesn't
translate right and that's what's going
to be interesting
after the pandemic is over will these
big tick tock stars be able to fill
arenas without no no no it's
it the smart the smart kids
and i know some of them and i say smart
meaning they're in the right place the
right time and they have abs i don't
mean smart
like they're contemplative geniuses
right i mean like they're
smart they found a way to parlay that
into something they're investing in
companies now and they're trying you
know they're launching energy drinks and
every week to have a fake company where
they're like
fizzle pop and they just sell it to the
fan base of people
and they try to invest in as many
companies and and
you know that's what they do because
that's the
before tick tock there were kids on vine
and all of those kids now uh live in
tents
on the side of the 101 or they're
selling [ __ ] right or whatever they're
doing but like
they didn't parlay that fame which came
very quickly
and without reason uh into anything
and that generation of people uh
just bombed out yeah and danny dobrik
turned it into something yeah devin
dobrik yeah devin dobrik
yeah and a complex to sexual assault is
what he turned it into yeah well he
but he's what has he got ben how much
money do you think he has uh david
on there it says like 10 million 10 15
million yeah this is his net worth
yeah that's enough by thailand he had a
run
i mean listen i don't know we too you
know the last episode we talked about
him a little bit i don't know what
but the smart ones fall back realize
they're not going to be famous forever
start investing in [ __ ] and they try to
figure out ways to
you know you know keep keep
stacking money but it it's a short
burn because your fans are 12. right so
when your fans grow up and get
girlfriends and boyfriends and figure
out that they're
human beings although maybe that'll
never happen now uh
you're out with the tick-tock world just
like you were out on vine
just like a lot of people that were on
youtube were out remember that guy fred
ben you told us that guy fred on youtube
yeah he was like big i remember fred and
he used to do like the
fast-forwarded voice right like that's
right his voice sound like that yeah
i'm nine yeah now what happened to fred
he's done
and he came out of the closet he's he's
he he did come out here he did come out
of the closet which was big
how do you know all this giannis because
um
pretends he doesn't know anything but he
knows everything i'm not a person who
sits there and reads science books
i'm someone who scrolls on my phone and
i'm my brain has been rotted just the
same as everybody else yeah you saw fred
at the grove ben
yeah at the grove that wasn't looking
good this was like 2016
2017. just getting ice cream well what's
the third act for fred there's really
nothing
he's getting blown in his sauna right
and he's at a he's at a russian bath
house
yeah well good for him i mean that's
that's better than i was i will say god
bless him he made
like three films fred one two and three
so you know
what was fred three like was that
starting to get a little weak
was fred three stretching a bit yeah
once he developed an adam's apple
and went through puberty like the gig
was up he had to stop
yeah it's a very interesting thing when
you think about what happens
to i mean but some of the kind of
stocking you know
she's very personable she's funny she's
you know she has
nice things about her i mean she's not
patrice you know what i
whenever i say somebody's funny on this
everyone comes at me she's no
[ __ ] funny hey hey buddy relax
she's not carlin right she's funny to
her fans right and
she's a personable young lady who's not
young
so i don't know what her gig is she'll
figure it out
right she's doing like a
she does like when he comes it keeps
going yeah whitney cummings
you will will keep going until the end
yeah
i mean just it's that charlton hessen
quote you want my gun out of my cold
dead hands
you want my followers like you know
they'll be like out of my cold dead
hands like these people are not going
away
until they do how about like a
sequel to cheers but it's uh cvs
pharmacy
and everyone knows your name it's like
certain people walking like bills come
in
yeah and they just they have our spot at
the bar
and they're just they're just there for
them
by the way that's all that's left in
america you go in these cities the only
thing you have is pharmacies
yeah so many of them on every corner cvs
a walgreens like
sweet shop yeah yeah its pharmacies are
big yeah
big farm is here pills are here pills
are here and
and they got everybody on them and i
feel like yeah if you're not taking
pills
if you're not taking pills you're not
working at buckies well there'll be
there'll be more vaccines too it's like
they'll be next year's vaccine like
they're not going to stop no
they'll be like they'll be like a whole
new industry yeah they'll be like this
is the next vaccine here's your booster
you give wait till the racism vaccine
that's going to be fun
no you just get vaccinated against your
own thoughts yeah don't think that's not
going to come
no i do i think they're going to figure
out a way to also remove testosterone
without making you a eunuch
yeah well big pharma will just come in
and go um
we found out you have a lot of troubling
thoughts and a lot of them are
are rooted in systems of oppression but
if you take
uh this pill uh you can you can kind of
be a modern person and then there'll be
certain people who act out fantasies as
the other sex
online but actual trans people in the
real world
will find out about that and those will
be
the the new kind of everyone talking
about people none of them are trans it's
hilarious
it's like most of these people that are
out there talking it's like
they're not like a person who's
transitioned to the another gender
they're like a non-binary person or
they're like
a person who's like i'm just queer and
call me this but you're like well d
like what have you like are you are you
walking the walk
like at least well that's what i'm
saying they will be mad that those
people aren't walking the walk and then
they'll march against them
i just can't wait because every year
some you know gay people now are like
your privilege and everything
soon people will turn on trans people
soon disabled people will have their day
right and then soon it'll be like people
will
will will turn on them like everyone
will get turned on eventually everyone
who has
we will turn around to a trans person in
a wheelchair eventually and go
you need to acknowledge your privilege
and you need to shut your mouth because
it'll just everyone's gonna have their
day in the sun and then that'll be yeah
everyone's getting sort of their 15
minutes of power right now it's
kind of instead of 15 minutes of fame
it's like 15 minutes of power it's like
we can't talk about you we can't say
anything for 15 minutes
and it's like a merry-go-round of like
every single marginalized group
is getting a little taste of what it
feels like to tell people
people take like posters down for
volleyball because it's ableist
yeah at lycologists yeah and this is
where we're at it's a
we're in a weird place they tried to
cancel a daddy daughter dances
oh wow and where i live they tried to
cancel daddy why because the gender
because uh it's not fair what if uh
it's a lesbian family it was all
hypotheticals too like there is no
lesbian family what if there was
two women who had a kid but who cares
they could go to it yeah i say the one
with the short hair send her
yeah right yeah yeah who cares yeah i
don't
i don't know anymore man they've turned
gay culture into this like
unfun thing where you just have to
lecture people all the time about what
words to say
and it's like what happened to the
[ __ ] and the fun and the drugs
and what happened to like who you are
who are you
past being asian or gay now when you
hear
anyone open their mouth on television
it's like you know it's coming
you know it's coming like well i'm
korean or i'm who just did snl danielle
daniel david dobrik who just guessed it
devin dobrik he comes out and he had
some funny jokes with the first line he
goes i'm black and i'm brilliant
it's the first thing you gotta say he's
the first thing you gotta say
is hi yeah from a black panther or
something right yeah
uh the black judas and the black messiah
oscar nominee
okay was he in black panther am i racist
i think he was yeah okay
but yeah the first thing is i'm playing
it's like the first thing you got to say
is it's like hey
yeah i'd have to if i was hosting
against an ally i have to walk out and
go
i'm gay yeah we there's no value in
having it easy you have to be able to
sell that you had it hard in some
make-believe way because things are so
that's sort of the flaw in freedom is
that we're free to complain right right
like the us saying how wrong things are
is evidence of how great things are
because we're allowed to say how wrong
there i think
lorne michael should nuke snl at the end
like when he's right about to go out and
just do one real good one
have louis like yeah that's a great idea
just nuke it with one really good show
that everyone will
complain about and hate and then just
end it yeah
end it end it end it just do one good
one
he's never gotten sick of that show i
mean he's going on what is it now how
many years
i think like 45 45 years man
45 years he owns a piece of almost
everybody who's gone through there after
a certain era
he makes them all sign a contract before
they audition any movie they do
anything they do they just stole someone
else's sketch like
they don't they don't have anything it's
the end yeah it's like everybody who
submits a writing packet to that yeah
it's all urban night at a club it's you
know they're about to get shut down by
the community board
and they're they're getting their last
that's what it is
that's what tv is it's urban night at
the club
that's what clubs do right before they
get closed down
they cash in as much as they can it is
very true yeah and that's why they're
going like you know we're doing a
hispanic show that's what clubs do we're
doing black knight we're doing hispanic
yeah that's right before it closes
because that's the last
that's the last kind of schtick pitch
open mics and
yeah that's the last thing uh i started
going to florida i just want to
live in florida there's something nice
about florida i don't know what it is
it's a dirty swamp and everybody's
accepted that life is hell
and there's just something nice about
that flo not miami either not that [ __ ]
i don't want to go there
i'm not trying to do that but like the
parts of florida that get it
i love my age i like it too but it's too
but
people there believe that things are
gonna be like i'm talking like
i want to go somewhere where people get
like they're either on a golf course or
they're
drunk at 4 pm staring at their wife
going
who's gonna drop first like miami's just
everyone's got their tits out and
everybody's like let's
we're making history and you know who's
got the time for that
no but the thing about miami that's
great is there's very little wokeness
it's all superficial
well that's why you need coke and
[ __ ] yeah you need
people to go on drugs and [ __ ] each
other
otherwise if you take sex out of the
equation and tell
everyone that they can't get can't like
you know
what it starts to happen is like i've
seen gay people now are miserable
remember when gay people used to be
happy they used to [ __ ] yeah
now they're miserable okay people like
you know what i've been feeling
is that and it's like why are you so
upset
you should be happy remember the geraldo
bit he's like i'm a little
i want gay guys to get married because
i'm a little sick of their carefree
lifestyle
it's we've turned it into a misery it's
like a miserable
and there's no the discrimination is is
no longer real i mean yeah okay so okay
somebody in arkansas said you were
fagging
because you you wore dressed to
chick-fil-a okay yes sorry
bad [ __ ] happens bad [ __ ] happens people
have small minds
but but also like the discrimination has
gone
down it's gone really really yeah yeah
and so instead of
celebrating that we've invented pretend
discrimination
fake discrimination and gay people are
now just miserable
they're miserable people
yeah and they're miserable people and
they don't even they're not getting
married like
everybody fought for marriage and
they're like [ __ ] that we're not even
going to do that
and they're like well we want to be able
to adopt kids how many of them are doing
that nobody's even doing that
so they go let's just be miserable and
then they're like well let's not go out
and [ __ ]
have fun let's go and tell everybody
that what pronouns should be in their
bio
and they should apologize for
imperialism and everything like that and
it's like
how long do you have on this planet how
long do you think you have on this
planet
how miserable do you want it to be yeah
and it just made me think that woody
allen documentary was probably the worst
advertisement for a doctor i mean he has
done
horrible things for adoption
people are now going i [ __ ] i would
adopt this kid but i don't want it to
[ __ ] my boyfriend
she adopted eight kids from yeah just by
the numbers one of them
she adopted a like a thai sex party
i mean she adopted am i wrong like she
adopted
a tie you know what do you think is
gonna happen yeah with every new adopted
rescued cambodian she
increased the chances that her boyfriend
was gonna [ __ ] she's like woody meet
the new one
fung ling meet fun ling
i mean he has really hurt there's a lot
of kids
who could be rescued from the jungle but
now people are having second thoughts
because they don't want their husband to
[ __ ] one of those
pharaoh in that doc and woody is
probably guilty right yeah he seems
guilty
he looks guilty he looks okay he looks
like a guy who's coveting your daughter
it's like every move he made is about
that but mia farrow in that documentary
also looks really bad like did no one at
the adoption agency i guess because
she's rich don't care but did
did anyone go do you need an eighth like
did anyone
stop her and go how many of these are
you going to have right here what are
you going to do
it's sort of like she needed a bartender
just said you've had enough yeah
you cut her off yeah cut her off cut her
off at
the eighth sex slave she adopted
and brought over here yes i mean you
can't just keep conti
you can't keep continuing to adopt
endlessly in perpetuity you need to
build a wall at some point
and close the border build a role around
your own family
yeah i think texas may soon build a wall
against californians yeah it's like a
real [ __ ]
uh you know and it's funny because they
are
all of them are living here and
collecting california unemployment which
is hilarious
everyone's like secretly collecting
california unemployment well the
pandemic ends
uh new york and la will retain their
prominence i think to a degree but i
also believe that like
because the world is so decentralized
now
there is going to be a little shift and
i i don't know how big that shift is
going to be it's anyone's guess
but i i do think people people are tired
of uh but new york is is amazing
california's amazing but people are also
just tired of the eye those two cities
are amazing ideas
that aren't functioning right now in the
way like it's like new york it's like if
you can make it here you can make it
anywhere but the
but it's like yeah but you can't make it
here and also california's got no point
now where it's like
it it it's such the difference between
the california you know from tv and
movies
and the real california is such a stark
contrast
that people are starting to go hey [ __ ]
this [ __ ] [ __ ] this like what is this
we're getting robbed here and
we're not getting anything out of it and
this place is an idea and the idea is
now a bad idea yeah and a lot of the
laws in these liberal places now
unfortunately are just being written by
sort of utopian notions
well it's like yeah it's like uh yeah
it's like uh like you told me there's a
law in california
you can't shoot someone if they enter
your house if you yeah you can't
have to prove that you tried to run away
yeah you got to try to run away if they
try to kill you
yes so i mean that's so you could get
sued or go to jail for killing someone
who broke into your house
we have people in congress right now
that think we should abolish not
not defund which is also [ __ ] but
for other reasons but like
abolish any type of police are you
talking
when you say people in congress are you
talking about the squad
people like that but there's other
people out there there's more than just
those four
and there are people that go we should
just send social workers
out to like the scene of a brutal rape
or whatever and i know everyone's going
to be like no but
cops don't do anything for rape it's
like sure but let's say they saw one in
progress
i think some of them would do something
and the idea that a social worker is
going to be able to help
when social work is like a pretend job
i think we should do it though let it go
for a year
just make sure it's filmed let the purge
yeah just
want to see it like just make sure we
can see the social worker
show up in his khaki shorts or his khaki
pants
with his sperry topsiders or
just some old fat black woman who shows
up with a clipboard
and starts asking questions and asks if
they have symptoms or what medications
they're on
and uh have they heard of fema and can
we get you know
sectioned it's like every like person i
know
who had had no clue like got into social
work or psychology which is the other
fake dignity like
i asked people like what are you
studying you know psychology i'm like oh
you have no you have no clue
uh i worked in social work and there's
two types of social workers at least in
the cities at least in new york
it's like like church-going black women
right right who like you know uh
who do good and then the other is like
the stupidest child in a jewish family
right like right he might have got
dropped or something
and he's just open-hearted and he wears
khakis and he has like sensible
shoes with rubber soles he's got three
shirts
yeah yeah and he's just he always has a
rash
and he just shows up he just shows up
and they just you just always
you're always filling out like
what medications are on and just asking
questions what medications are you on
right and you just you never fix
anything because you can't right that's
the thing that people don't understand
you can't fix it you just kind of are
there
to have a job yeah just you're just
constantly asking of what medications
you're on yeah
and if we should uh change that
and then once in a while you get a
coffee mug thrown at your head and you
call 9-1-1
and nothing's fixed nothing can nobody
gets better
none of the therapies work you know
i worked in an sro and you know we took
homeless people up the street and then
what those people did who had apartments
in the street
is they started bringing garbage in from
the street into their apartment
this is true story they wanted to live
in the street they enjoyed some of them
would disappear and live on the street
for a little bit
right and then you'd ask them what
medications they were on and then it
would be next tuesday
and you'd ask them what medications they
were on yeah it's
mental health care in this country is
really just a non-event
it's just uh no one cares yeah i mean
my point is is like social workers it's
a very noble job everyone should do it
uh i there it should be like a college
credit you learn a lot you you it gives
you empathy it lets you know that some
mental illness a lot of times makes
people lose their jobs also
or or live on the street also no family
a lot of us don't realize like without
family
if your family disappears there's a good
not not everyone's just gonna be a pull
you're up by
pull yourself up by your own bootstraps
type of independence
nobody's gonna be not everyone's p diddy
who's gonna create his own [ __ ] right
you know but no that's with the
libertarians that go hey man we're gonna
hey just start a paper route figure it
out start a job
yeah you know nobody everyone doesn't
know some of our ideas are like
yeah that would have been good had that
been what we started at yeah we're here
now
yeah so excited lewis j gomez didn't
start gas digital
i mean yeah yeah dave smith will be
yelling about libertarian values into
a cup right and louis is amazing loses
success story lewis is one of those guys
who like can do it
yeah but so many people in the world
can't do it everyone needs a little help
is my point like
it's not that sort of ideal that just
pulls you even billionaires yes
and that's i think billionaires they
need people to rob that's why
the government gives all these big
realtors in new york all these
development companies in new york city
they give them
tax abatements so they can build condos
and tribeca with floating bathtubs
that's important it's just super
important to have people have a shower
with 19 heads in it
and and and don't worry don't think that
the tent cities
are a problem i think we need limestone
and you know venetian marble flown in
and keep the tenses give them addresses
they should just [ __ ] get mail
no it was a problem i knew things were
like taking a turn
when like um people were starting to say
things in new york they were going like
this house is 20 million dollars to go
but it's not yet in the ultra luxury
market
and i'm like wait a minute what is the
ultralight and they're like well that's
50 million and above i'm going
and then you look at who's buying his
apartment it was all like dictators and
blood money
and [ __ ] people that poisoned rivers
and zambia
people that were wanted at the hague for
war crimes but those are people that
get things done yeah they do things
that's my point i was making about
social workers is like kids who've never
done social work don't understand that
empathy is in perpetuity
it never ends you show up every day how
do you feel tell me how you're feeling
what are your medications
you know tell me how you feel and all is
it that never ends
right at some point you have to go what
are we gonna do right
and that's not what social workers do
right they never go what are we gonna do
they always go tell me about your
feelings what medications are you on
so it's like at some point you need a
cop to do something
at some point you need force or an
action to move
something you can't just perpetually be
uh empathetic nothing gets done if
everyone's just
talking and making sure everyone's okay
that's a good point yeah
johnny long days johnny [ __ ] long
days what i'm trying to say is replace
even uh not go we shouldn't we shouldn't
replace cops with social workers
we should replace social workers with
more cops yeah
we should get rid of the social workers
and give them more cops
yeah yeah i think someone should walk in
and put a gun on the table
that would be funny if that was the
counter march instead of like defund the
police were like no
don't replace replace the social workers
with more cops
militarize the social workers military
give the social workers guns
yeah give them guns give them guns a
good idea give them a badge and guns and
just swear them in like a western
women and those unsuccessful jewish guys
guns deputize those social workers
now
tell people where they can find you uh
they could find me uh
on unemployment no they could find me
they could find me if anyone asks named
rogan in austin
um now you can find me on uh twitter
uh you know instagram you know just
listen to long days i hope you guys come
over start listening to the podcast
and um just yeah you can uh subscribe to
it on itunes or spotify or you could
watch it on youtube
giannis was the guy we did this is
hilarious
we did say a plague like we needed a
plague yeah
that was crazy it was crazy and people
were sending it to me going like holy
[ __ ] you guys
called what was what was happening i
thought they were like [ __ ] around
then i watch it i'm like oh no they're
dead
deadly serious another thing they're
sending me recently is somebody posted a
live in gotham said i did where i
apparently said
in the year 2022
i said in the joke 2022 china china is
going to attack
so they're saying that i'm saying that
if they attack in 2022 i called it an
alive and gotham joke i think you i
think you called it
two years late yeah
i think this was it i think there's
gonna be an hr meeting
at the tim dillon show i think ladies
and gentlemen
thank you for listening we appreciate it
tim dillon ben every go follow you
honest papas yani long days
on youtube patreon everywhere you get
podcasts and we will see
you soon thank you